[Applause]
after a grueling a 26-mile marathon
Detective Sergeant Nick Bailey can't
quite believe he has reached a finish
line I took quite a not last year with
the knowledge shock poisoning both
mentally and physically not me a little
bit and I wanted to have something to
focus on and work towards but I also at
the same time wanted to give to me back
to the hospital the 38 year old spent
several weeks in intensive care
after he was exposed to the deadly nerve
agent another joke last year the
Wiltshire police officer is lucky to be
alive he was one of the first responders
to arrive at a contaminated house of the
former Russian spy Sergei scrapple
recalling the moment he was left in a
critical condition he said he never
thought he would be able to take part in
today's event physically and mentally
it's been a bit of a roller coaster
it's been quite difficult to come to
terms a lot of things that's happened to
us over the last 18 months but you just
keep battling through it questions
remain over who was behind another talk
attack but he didn't want to be drawn
into that saying his focus is to raise
as much money as possible for the
doctors that saved his life
my targets 15,000 if I don't hit 15,000
it doesn't matter it's still an amazing
amount of money together hand over to
the hospital such a good cause they're
amazing bunch of people so I'm I'm
really pleased that I've been there to
race that much Detective Sergeant Bailey
was determined to finish today's
marathon and he has done so for his
local district hospital in Salisbury no
Philips Sky News